heute geht's auf eine reise wohin das
verrate ich euch noch nicht aber ich
sage euch das wird richtig spannend wie
es endgültig hatte vermissen
vom baby kartoffeln weiß das jemand
[Musik]
wichtig zu sehen dass fabian hambüchen
moment moment ich glaube ich muss an der
stelle erst mal ein bisschen ausholen
bei meinem ersten reisestopp werde ich
ein problem angehen dass mich ehrlich
gesagt schon länger wurmt und behind the
scenes arbeite ich da deswegen schon
seit ein paar wochen ganz fleißig mit
fabian zusammen an einem neuen projekt
es geht darum dass wenn ich in einem
video über zum beispiel einen speziellen
tomaten dünger spreche den ich euch
gerne empfehlen weil ich ihn super gerne
verwende oder ein kultur schutznetz das
besonders stabiles und nicht sofort
kaputt geht sondern dass man ganz lange
verwenden kann dann möchte ich euch
diese sachen natürlich immer gerne in
der video beschreibung verlinken damit
ihr sie euch nach kaufen könnt weil
sonst kriege ich erstens von euch ärger
und zweitens sind die empfehlungs links
für mich doch ne total wichtige
einkommensquelle damit ich die videos
hier überhaupt machen kann weil mit so
einem kanal ja auch große ausgaben
einhergehen und großer aufwand dahinter
steckt nicht nur von mir sondern auch
von meinem team und die will ich
natürlich auch fair bezahlen für ihre
tolle arbeit und bisher habe ich leider
keine andere möglichkeit als diese
empfehlungs links immer über amazon zu
setzen und es stinkt mir ehrlich gesagt
weil ich diesen laden eigentlich
überhaupt nicht unterstützen möchte
gleichzeitig aber auch das einkommen
angewiesen bin dass ich über die
empfehlungs links habe mein freund
fabian hier hat durch corona viel
weniger arbeit als vorher
und deswegen möchte er einen garten shop
aufbauen oder haben wir uns gedacht wie
cool wäre das eigentlich wenn ich ihn
jetzt weil den shop aufbaut genau sagen
kann welche sachen erde aufnehmen soll
weil ich die heiß und innig liebe und
ich dann von jetzt an auf ihn verlinken
kann ihn unterstützen kann und von
diesen bescheuerten essen links weg
komme ja das ist fabian ja er macht den
job
dafür gibt es noch nicht
er freut mich vor allem dass du dass du
ja dazu gesagt hast mich dabei zu
unterstützen beim einem neuen projekt
sozusagen und vor allem bei der produkt
finden da auch ratschläge so aufregend
finde ich keine diese phase mit dem
ganzen übersprudelnd von ideen und
biologie das alles werden wird das wird
glaube ich richtig cool es ist für euch
richtig cool wenn ihr einen ort habe
hier die produkte einkaufen können die
ich empfehle es ist für mich cool wenn
ich nicht auf immer sinnvoll denken muss
man schon gar nicht mehr warten bis es
losgeht und warum ich damit ihr zu sagen
dass auf diese reise zu gehen ja
[Musik]
wie tief es runter geht
ich habe ich den kühlen angst kann
jemand erwarten den gast in der stadt
hier sind wurde
ich fände es auf jeden fall richtig toll
wenn du schnecken kragen aufnehmen
können ist und das ist einfach in der
methode die man schnecken wird am
effizientesten kurs werden kann und da
gibt es so viel sport immer spezielle
vorstellungen schon jahre jedenfalls
kapital für den super schnell kaputt und
ich finde wenn man plastik im garten
verwendet das ist okay aber nur wenn man
es hat jahre lang verwenden kann das
nicht einfach so wegschmeißen muss oder
ausdrucke sind ein bisschen teil
meinst du das ist vielleicht sinnvoller
da ich finde es cool ich also soll so
ein haus aus metall das erschwinglich
sein
aber vielleicht können wir auch zwei ja
nicht immer so dass die leute sich dann
ja letztendlich dann ihre entscheidung
ist es war auf jeden fall kein problem
diese liste zusammen zu kriegen mit den
sachen die am anfang schon in den shops
sein und das hat mir super viel spaß
gemacht da mitzuwirken
und dann sind auch schon die ersten
antworten von den herstellern rein
geflattert und es ging darum zu
entscheiden welche sachen können wir
nehmen welche nicht zu welchen
konditionen und so weiter das hätte ich
am anfang tatsächlich nicht so erwartet
wie viel arbeit darin steckt also hut ab
wie dass er das gerade alles so scheiße
gemacht und wenn ihr ideen ab wie gesagt
schreibt uns auf jeden fall in die
kommentare welche sachen ihr euch im
shop wünschen würde damit wir dann auch
eure ideen mit einbringen können nicht
mein für euch machen wir das jahr hat
ihr mann der ideen ich erstatte wir sind
ja genau wir sind in münchen und wisst
ihr wir hier ganz in der nähe wohnt
kommt jemand drauf sehr schwer zu
erraten dem titelbild zu sehen ist wir
gucken lassen
[Musik]
na bist du von fans an gefälscht man
kann nicht mehr normal einkaufen
[Musik]
wir sind im ricordo land
da ist er
die sind als dachplatten dank fürs
spielen aus da hinten und den knoblauch
an jetzt der hammer schaut mal eine
dicke dinger ja noch zwei monate
[Musik]
die hab ich noch die journey prinz war
eine lieblings tomaten
wir sind ein bisschen verbrannt in der
sonne leider muss man immer aufpassen
ananas tomate mit der hast du mich jetzt
auch geködert die habe ich jetzt auch
sehr schicke ich nur empfehlen will aber
nicht zu viel versprechen weil je
nachdem wo sie wächst in welchen boden
mit welchen bedingungen und so wo die
samen herkommen kann es immer
unterschiedlich sein
was ist die erde sei ja oder nein süße
fruchtige mit großen früchten
mittelgroße bis große nicht so groß wie
die anderen das thema hatte aber
mittelgroße ist groß und bei mir
zumindest unheimlich intensiver tomaten
geschmack und süßen weitere fruchtig du
hast gehört von anderen dass es bei den
nicht so lecker ist oder wie sie genau
viele probieren es ja aus und sagen mir
schmeckt's nicht und entweder sind die
geschmäcker einfach unterschiedlich aber
es sind ganz häufig die bodenbedingungen
was für mineralstoffe und so habe ich im
boden was mit der bodenbeschaffenheit
wie ging ich wie viel wasser schmeißt
hin
ganz wichtig wenn nicht wasser wasser
wasser ohne ende dann schmecken sie halt
auch westen ja auf jeden fall hast du
schon mal diese noch nie gehört noch nie
gehadert
die ist auch nicht so verbreitet in
deutschland dabei das ist dieses jahr
meine große hoffnung weil ich habe so
gute sachen über die gehört wer die
beste tomate auf der welt habe so eine
schöne kolben hirse so eine ganz große
liste die als wiener vater oder auch
selber zum meisten sowohl-als-auch also
in erster linie für mich aber es wird
viel übrigbleiben schätze ich und für
die genau und für die vögel
ich mache auch sonnenblumen und hirse
und sowas lasse ich dann im herbst
stehen ja und da sind perfektes vor
bewusst die draußen
sie sehen auch toll auswahl wir haben
eben stand garten rundgang gedreht den
könnt ihr beim florian auf dem kanal
anschauen dann aber wir machen jetzt
noch mal was für pflanzen noch mal was
du da ja bei mir muss unbedingt jeder
mal in die im boden
sojabohnen ja das geht ja der florian
hat hier auf jeden fall ziemlich coole
schnecken kragen habe ich gerade gesehen
und auch die aus metall da haben wir in
münchen auch schon viel darüber geredet
die letzten tage finde ich richtig gut
und du bist auch richtig zufrieden zu
geben oder
also da kannst du kannst nichts machen
wie sollen die denker pte mja kosten
auch nicht also super die hier aus
plastik mit denen habe ich auch gute
erfahrungen gemacht aber wer sich
erinnert an den großen hagel im rekord
die land den haben die nicht überstanden
also da muss man abwägen die sind halt
teurer
die sind auch gut für klassik schnecken
kreiden diese zensur lange alter hut
[Musik]
wie riesig der kommt in die küche der
ist noch gut
also wir haben unseren jetzt gerade auf
gewechselt da er sagt so aus sondern
möglicherweise verlängert
[Musik]
wenn du dir jetzt ernte ist dann
irgendwann die idee der name wie
bereitest du zu früh ernten also wenn
sie noch jung sind die schotten aber
wenn man schon sieht dass die kerne sich
ausbilden dann die kompletten schoten
ernten im wasser kochen bis sogar sind
23 minuten und dann herausnehmen aus dem
wasser wissen salz drüber grobes salz
und mit sojasoße bisschen sojasauce
eintunken also die kerne aus der schote
dann auszuziehen oder schmeckt so gut
man hat man das salzige auf den lippen
war köstlich ich muss was man deiner
minister probiere ich einfach gerne ins
trinkwasser einfach so ein 2 das wasser
und das aromatisiertes wasser so gut
danach teilen sichere plassmann beim
problem ist halt wieder so viel zucker
dir einfach was auch violette dann
praktisch
das sind zur gemusterte oder ich kenne
sie als fußboden und ich mag sie
geschmacklich nicht so gerne aber sie
sehen hammer mäßig aus okay dann haben
sie sind es bei mir unten durch
sie müssen schnell dass ich mal wohnen
angepflanzt was die interesse ich weiß
es nicht ich habe es bis jetzt noch
nicht ausprobiert sie sind winzig klein
es gibt so viele nicht geplant
es ist so schön weil egal wie lange du
geld hast du kannst jedes jahr aufs neue
entdecken ich mache im august
wahrscheinlich wieder im garten youtuber
treffen wir wenn es dann klappt also
waren mal alles so als würde es klappen
drückt mir die daumen und du bist hier
mit ganz offiziell natürlich kennt ihr
das garten youtuber treffen machen ist
dann natürlich mit dabei von der partie
wir treffen uns alle hier im garten und
haben ein schönes wochenende wir kochen
zusammen mit quatschen zusammen wir
filmen zusammen machen auch filme
natürlich
wir machen einen gemeinsamen großen live
stream immer also wenn es klappt mache
es wenn es nicht geht